ya aterrizó en Londres la primera parada
de una visita por Europa que durará
cuatro días vaiden cumplirá con un
pendiente dialogar con el Rey Carlos III
sobre medio ambiente la reunión se dará
después del encuentro con el Primer
Ministro británico
celebrado entre los mandatarios esta se
da Poco después de que Estados Unidos
anunciara el envío de municiones de
racimo a Ucrania una decisión que divide
a los miembros de la otan y que podría
estar en la agenda
Reino Unido destinatario de una
convención que prohíbe la producción o
el uso de municiones de racimo y
desalienta su uso continuaremos haciendo
nuestra parte Para apoyar a Ucrania
contra la invasión ilegal y no provocada
de Rusia
luego biden pasará dos días en la
capital de lituania escenario de la
Cumbre anual de la otan la posición de
la alianza transnacional sobre Ucrania
sigue sin resolverse
en una entrevista exclusiva a CNN biden
afirmó que era muy pronto para que
Ucrania entrara a la otan y que la
invasión de Rusia debe terminar antes de
que kiev pueda unirse a la alianza una
declaración que contrasta con el
objetivo del presidente ucraniano
creo que no hay suficiente unidad en
esta área y esto es una amenaza para la
fuerza de la alianza solo estamos
esperando resultados positivos O al
menos un paso en dirección correcta el
viaje culminará en Finlandia el último
país en unirse a la otan la visita será
radicalmente diferente a la última de un
mandatario estadounidense en helsinki
Entonces el expresidente Donald Trump
llevó a cabo una conferencia de prensa
con Vladimir Putin